Herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio 265, wo wir uns heute mit einer virtuellen Welt beschäftigen wollen. Einer Welt, die zwischen den Jahren vielen Menschen sehr viel Freude gemacht hat, nämlich die RC3 World. Was das genau ist, wie die entstanden ist und ob man die sich auch selber bauen kann, das klären wir heute alles hier und ich begrüße recht herzlich meine Gäste. Katti, hallo.
Hallo.
Roang, hallo. Und das Hackhörnchen, hallo.
Hi zusammen.
Das sind vier von denen, ich vermute nicht die einzigen, sondern vielen Menschen, die es möglich gemacht haben, dass es auf dem Chaos Communication Congress oder Remote Chaos Experience, das muss ich gleich auch nochmal nachfragen, dass es da eine Welt gab, in der man sich so computerspielmäßig zusammenfinden konnte. Das war so, von oben sieht man so eine kleine schöne Pixel-Grafik und da kann man rumlaufen und wenn man bei anderen in die Nähe kommt, dann geht die Webcam auf und das Mikrofon an, wenn man will, sodass man Leute quasi auch treffen kann und all das wurde, wie es halt beim Chaos Kongresso ist, selbst gebaut. Was das bedeutet, das wollen wir heute rausfinden. Und ich vermute, diese Sendung wird vor allen Dingen von Menschen gehört, die dabei waren und das miterlebt haben, jetzt wissen wollen, wie das geht. Ich würde das chronologisch erzählen wollen, liebe Gemeinde, und als erstes mal fragen, wann war das erste Mal, dass jemand dachte, hey, vielleicht können wir da irgendwas basteln?
Also wenn wir ganz am Anfang anfangen, da hatten wir ein großes Treffen im April, eigentlich so zur Nach- vorbereitung vom 36C3, wo man sich eben zusammenfindet und mal ein bisschen drüber redet, was kann man so verbessern an den üblichen Events? Und da war natürlich unsere werte Pandemie schon so voll dabei. Und wir saßen alle zu Hause und haben überlegt, was ist, wenn das jetzt länger dauert? Und da hat sich eine kleine Gruppe gefunden, die gesagt hat, ja, wir sollten mal gucken, ob wir nicht was remote machen können. Und daraus ist es dann entstanden.
Und war das dann so, dass alle sofort so dabei waren, ja, geil, lass uns was remote machen, oder war dann eher so, das ersetzt das ja nicht, na, ist das wirklich eine gute Idee?
Ich wünschte, sie wären alle voll dabei gewesen. Diese Gruppe ist eine ganze Weile recht klein geblieben und hat Ideen gesammelt und sich angeguckt, was existiert denn schon, was funktioniert denn für Menschen und was funktioniert vor allem auch für die Chaos-Community. Aber es kam eben auch ganz viel, ich sag mal, Müdigkeit von außen. So eine Pandemie ist natürlich auch anstrengend. So ein Event zu veranstalten braucht viel Kraft und sehr, sehr viel Zeit. Und da das natürlich alles freiwillig organisiert wird, haben viele Menschen, die üblicherweise ganz vorne dabei sind, gesagt, remote ist nicht meins, so eine Pause täte eigentlich mal ganz gut. Und deshalb waren wir ein kleiner Kreis, der auch an vielen Stellen mit den üblichen Verdächtigen aus der Projektleitung gar nicht so viel zu tun hatte, die überlegt haben, was wir machen können.
Okay, und wie viele Leute waren das dann insgesamt, die an dieser Welt mitgebaut haben?
Das ist sehr schwierig zu sagen. Erstmal müssten wir irgendwie abgrenzen, was heißt denn mitbauen. Aber wenn wir so alles irgendwie dazunehmen, das heißt einerseits Menschen, die Code schreiben, natürlich Menschen, die sich überlegen, wie das Ganze dann irgendwie deployed wird. Ich meine, wir mussten haben mehrere Server und das muss ja irgendwie auch orchestriert werden. Dann hatten wir Menschen, die Karten gebaut haben. Wir hatten Menschen, die sich so ein bisschen um die Koordination des Ganzen gekümmert hat. Ich würde mal behaupten, so zwischen 15 und 20 Menschen, die da sehr, sehr viel Arbeit reingesteckt haben, waren es dann doch.
Noch zusätzlich zu dem waren halt die ganzen Assembly-Kartenbauer, die jetzt mit unserem Team nicht direkt zu tun hatten, sondern eigene Faust ihre Karten erstellt und dann praktisch einfach eingebunden haben.
Okay, die Assemblies darf man natürlich nicht vergessen. Ohne die wäre diese ganze Welt so dann auch nicht gewesen, wie sie war.
Also vielleicht könnt ihr noch mal ein bisschen genauer erklären, wie das eigentlich dann im Endeffekt aussah, weil was sie am Anfang gemacht haben, war ja nur eine sehr rudimentäre Schildung. Aber vielleicht könnt ihr mal sozusagen eine Führung, eine kurze Führung durch diese Welt machen. Also es ist ja so, wenn man angekommen ist als Nutzerin, dann stand man auf, wie gesagt, so einer Pixel-Grafik, da war die Rocket zu sehen, also diese Rakete, die immer vor dem Chaos-Communication-Congress rumsteht oder auch auf dem Camp, die Fairy Dust. Und dann war halt sozusagen so eine Art Eingang. Und dann konnte man da mit seinem Männchen, das man sich vorher erschaffen hat, rumlaufen. Aber dieses Rumlaufen, wohin ist man da gelaufen?
Also im Endeffekt ist es so gewesen, die einzelnen Welten waren wirklich einzelne Instanzen. Und diese Instanzen haben praktisch ihre Leute gekannt, die da herumgelaufen sind. Also wenn man sich zur Fairy Dust hingestellt hat, dann ist man praktisch mit allen Leuten, die in der Lobby, hat die Welt geheißen, gemeinsam auf einem Server gewesen. Die einzelnen Assemblies waren dann wieder einzelne Server. Das heißt, wir haben praktisch einfach die Verteilung der Menschen übernommen im Hintergrund. Und so das funktioniert.
Also wir haben uns anfangs einfach überlegt, wir wollen ja, dass jedes Assembly seine Karte, seine Welt gestalten und beitragen kann. Und dann braucht es natürlich irgendwie eine, naja, sagen wir mal Übersicht oder irgendwas, wie man da hinkommt. Und da haben sich dann Menschen zusammengefunden. Unser großartiges Maps-Team und haben sich ein bisschen überlegt, wie man das denn machen kann. Haben einerseits die Lobby, von der ihr gerade schon erzählt habt, gestaltet und von der aus abgehend dann noch mal so kleine Unterwelten, die ein kleines bisschen thematisch sortiert waren und sich so ein bisschen an so einer Super Mario Level Wechselkarte orientiert haben. Na eben einfach sehr, sehr viele Ausgänge mit Wegen dazwischen und ein bisschen Design und Gestaltung hatten. Und so konnte man dann von der Lobby-Karte erst mal in eine thematische Übersichtskarte wechseln, so irgendwie Hacker Spaces Nord, Hacker Spaces Süd zum Beispiel. Und von dort aus dann auf die einzelnen Karten der Assemblies weiter wechseln.
Okay, ich hatte jetzt eher eine bildhafte Beschreibung gemacht, weil ich gar nicht so über Ruhe gekommen bin. Und im Vorfeld der Sendung hat das anscheinend bei ganz vielen Leuten auch wieder Erinnerungen daran wachgerufen. Und anscheinend war ein großes Highlight auch die vielen Klos, die eingerichtet wurden. Also es gab genügend sanitäre Anlagen. Man musste auch fast gar nicht anstehen, was für einen Chaos-Congress wirklich sehr ungewöhnlich ist. Und da waren halt so liebevoll in diesen einzelnen, also haben wir es schon gelernt, das war wie so Level. Und das heißt wiederum, es waren einzelne Instanzen. Was das bedeutet, können wir nachher noch darüber sprechen. Gab es halt so Stände. Und dann hat man halt also wirklich auch Leute oder Gruppen, die man normalerweise auf dem Kongress sieht, auch da wiederum gesehen.
Okay, zurück.
Es gab also diese Idee. Da war halt eine riesige Gruppe von Menschen beteiligt. Also 20 in dem Kernteam, die sozusagen das technische Gerüst gebaut haben. Und dann noch drum herum. Also jede Gruppe, die einen eigenen Level gebaut hat, musste dann auch nochmal Menschen beschäftigen. Wie seid ihr denn da vorgegangen? War sofort klar. Okay, wir machen jetzt eine Top-Down-Perspektive. Wir machen Pixel-Grafik.
Los geht's. Anfangs haben wir erst mal überlegt, was für Software wir überhaupt dafür verwenden. Und da gab es dann eben so eine Konferenz ohne irgendwie ein Element, bei dem man sich begegnen kann. Einfach nur Vorträge anhören und gucken. Ist irgendwie langweilig. Haben wir das ganze Jahr über auch immer mal wieder bei kleineren oder anderen Veranstaltungen ausprobiert und gesehen. Und das Event-Feeling kam da einfach nicht so rüber. Also haben wir irgendwie mal überlegt und gesucht, was es an Software gibt oder was man denn da machen könnte, um das zu verbessern. Die Idee zu so einem Spiel kam da sehr, sehr schnell, aber alles noch sehr, sehr unausgereift. Und so ein, na, das Typische, man könnte mal. Und dann kam irgendwann tatsächlich Linus um die Ecke und meinte, hier, guckt mal, ich hab das letztens gesehen, guckt euch das doch mal an. Und dann haben wir dieses Work-Adventure entdeckt. Und dann war das plötzlich auch sehr, sehr konkret, wie das denn aussehen könnte.
Könntest du das noch mal sagen, ihr habt was entdeckt?
Das Work-Adventure, das ist die Software, die da hinten dran stand, die diese Welt möglich gemacht hat. Und das heißt, diese Entscheidung, dass das so ein Top-Down ist und dass das Pixel-Grafiken sind, wurde uns quasi dadurch abgenommen, dass uns jemand eine Software hingeworfen hat und gesagt hat, guckt euch das doch mal an. Und wir gesagt haben, jawoll, ungefähr sowas wollen wir haben.
Und diese Software ist normalerweise für?
Die Software hat eine französische Firma, The Coding Machine, entwickelt. Meines Wissens nach, weil ihnen das Homeoffice und die anderen nicht treffen können, auch so ein bisschen auf die Nerven ging, wie wir das wahrscheinlich alle während Corona ein bisschen erlebt haben, und sich dann gedacht haben, wir bauen uns da einfach eine Welt, in der wir unser Büro vielleicht ein bisschen nachbauen können und in der wir uns treffen und begegnen können, in der wir Meetings abhalten können, und so entstand das.
Und das war, also, ihr habt dann diese Software verwendet, oder habt ihr euch darin orientiert und was eigenes gebaut?
Wir haben die Software verwendet und sie einerseits um ein paar Dinge erweitert und andererseits ein paar Dinge davon strukturell auch einfach umgebaut, damit wir sie eben für so eine Veranstaltung wie den Remote-Congress benutzen können und damit sie dann auch mit der Instanzierung und mit den vielen Besuchern klarkommt.
Das heißt, das war Open-Source-Software?
Genau, das ist Open-Source-Software. Gibt es auf GitHub, kann man sich runterladen, kann auch jeder selbst betreiben, wenn er möchte. In der Zwischenzeit bietet die Firma eine Bezahlversion für zum Beispiel Events oder wenn man das in seiner Firma irgendwie benutzen möchte an, dann muss man sich da nicht selbst darum kümmern. Man kann das aber eben auch einfach runterladen und selbst betreiben.
So, dann stelle ich mir vor, also in dieser Software gibt es schon, sind diese Avatare angelegt, die man sich zusammenklicken kann und diese Grundfunktionalität von hier, hier gibt es Räume, wo man durchlaufen kann. Und dann frage ich mich sozusagen, es gab nicht dieses Ding, wenn man, also das war, man kann das natürlich auch ausschalten, konnte das auch ausschalten, aber es gab die Möglichkeit, wenn man da durchgelaufen ist und einem anderen Avatar nahe gekommen ist, dass dann automatisch die Webcam und das Mikrofon an- und aufgeht und man sich quasi wie bei einer Begegnung halt sozusagen auch da begegnet. War das schon Teil dieses Software?
Das war schon Teil der Software.
Okay und dieses, dass man die Räume wechseln muss und sozusagen nicht auf einer Karte bleibt, das war auch schon dabei?
Also auch Räume wechseln war schon Teil der Software. Was wir dazu dann noch so ein bisschen eingebaut bzw. nachgepflegt haben, war, dass man dabei eben auch, na sagen wir, die Instanz wechseln kann. Da kann Roang, glaube ich, deutlich mehr dazu sagen, weil er da technisch einfach mit drin steckt. Aber dieses Räume wechseln, mehrere Räume haben, war prinzipiell alles schon Teil der Software. Wir haben sehr, sehr viel, also sehr, sehr viel grafisch nachgearbeitet. Einerseits Animationen eingebaut. Andererseits zum Beispiel auch die Avatare erweitert. Es gab wahnsinnig viel Custom-Avatar-Auswahloptionen, speziell jetzt für den Remote-Congress. Da haben sich auch Menschen sehr, sehr viel Mühe einfach gegeben, das zu gestalten. Und da haben wir eben versucht, das Ganze so ein bisschen mehr Congress-Feelings mäßig zu machen.
Okay, dann können wir vielleicht zu dieser Instanzierung gleich nochmal kommen. Vielleicht könnt ihr nochmal ganz kurz für die Menschen, die es vielleicht doch nicht wissen, erklären, was Instanzierung eigentlich bedeutet.
Ganz einfach gesprochen, jeder Server kann eine bestimmte Menge an Leuten beinhalten. Da geht es einfach darum, der Server erhält die Bewegungsdaten und leitet sie an alle anderen weiter oder auch die Video- und Signaldaten teilweise. Wenn man sich jetzt vorstellt, wir haben teilweise 1500 Leute gehabt, das geht sich auf einen Server einfach nicht mehr aus. Und um das zu verhindern oder um das abzufedern, haben wir einfach mehrere Server aufgestellt, die alle die gleiche Software bedient haben, aber unterschiedliche Karten. Das heißt, wenn man in eine Assembly gegangen ist, das hat eine eigene Instanz, also einen eigenen Server mit der kompletten Software gehabt.
Und das ist also aus Nutzerinnenperspektive, hat das den folgenden Effekt, man ist in der Lobby und sagt, lass uns doch mal links rausgehen in diese nächste Ebene, und dann kommt man hin. Und dann ist man da möglicherweise gar nicht mehr zusammen. Trotzdem ist man im selben Raum. Und das ist halt genau diesen Effekt, den eine Instanz macht. Sie lässt halt kleinere Gruppen auf einem, das ist wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so, aber ein Computer kümmert sich um 15 Leute. Und ein anderer um die nächsten 15, deswegen kann man im selben Raum sein, ohne dass man sich gegenseitig sieht. Wie schwierig ist es, sowas zu bauen? Wie lange habt ihr denn daran gesessen? Weil das merkt man ja im besten Fall gar nicht als Nutzerin. Also was ganz Unsichtbares, aber stell dich mir technisch nicht so trivial vor.
Das war überraschend einfach. Das Komplizierteste war daran, dass wir praktisch den Hintergrund verändern. Wir haben es dann ganz einfach gelöst. Keep it simple, keep it safe. Wir haben einfach den Tab neu geladen. Also wir haben praktisch wirklich die Seite gewechselt. Das war auch der Grund dafür, dass immer am Anfang die Abfrage gekommen ist für Audio, Video, teilweise Avatar, weil man da wirklich komplett neu geladen haben, die Software praktisch. Aber somit haben wir es einfach und schnell lösen können für uns.
Und es gab ja dann sozusagen den Hack, dass man doch zusammen mit jemandem sein konnte, wenn man diese Adresse, die Zeile im Adressbrowser, die Adresseile im Browser einfach kopiert und dann weitergegeben hat. Ist euch das nicht vorher klar gewesen, dass die Leute ein starkes Bedürfnis haben werden, doch im selben Raum mit jemand ganz bestimmten zu sein? Oder war das dann zu kompliziert, das zu implementieren?
Grundsätzlich haben wir versucht, die Instanzanzahl möglichst klein zu halten. Das, was uns vorher eigentlich klar hätte sein sollen, aber naja, dass die Lobby die meistbesuchte Karte ist, wo sich die Leute am meisten treffen und dort das Bedürfnis am größten ist, zusammenzukommen, war im Nachhinein klar, aber dann nicht mehr leicht änderbar. Also in den Assemblies war es, glaube ich, nur in der Barkarte rechts, wo mir gerade der Name nicht einfällt. Die Lounge, danke. Die hat mehrere Instanzen gehabt, aber sonst die Assemblies haben alle eine Instanz gehabt für die meiste Zeit des Kongress.
Unser ursprünglicher Plan war eigentlich auch, und zwar klar, dass die Lobby sehr, sehr stark bevölkert wird oder dass da erst mal sehr, sehr viele Menschen sein werden, weil sie eben dort joinen. Und unser eigentlicher Gedanke war auch dort, die Kommunikation zu unterbinden und das einfach nur so als Durchschleussbereich zu benutzen. Das ging dann zwischendurch ein kleines bisschen unter, und dann konnte man sich dann doch dort unterhalten. Und NutzerInnen haben das auch sehr, sehr gerne getan. Und dann haben wir uns einfach dagegen entschieden, das dort stunden zu stellen und haben gesagt, dann ist das halt im Zweifel so, dass man sich da nicht treffen kann. Aber so abgewägt war es dann halt einfach an der Stelle irgendwie das Sinnvollste und Einfachste, was wir tun können. Und dass man sich dann im Zweifel dort mal nicht trifft, mussten wir irgendwie in Kauf nehmen.
So, dann damit haben wir sozusagen, was ihr technisch klären musstet bis dahin. Wir kommen gleich noch sozusagen, wie viel Technik man da irgendwo hinstellen muss. Aber es würde mich auch interessieren. Ihr habt jetzt gesagt, so 20 Leute, das ist natürlich für so ein riesiges Projekt eigentlich nicht viel. Aber andererseits, wenn man weiß, Menschen arbeiten zusammen, dann können 20 Leute auch ziemlich viele sein. Nämlich 20 Leute, die man ja auch irgendwie zusammenkriegen muss. Wie habt ihr das denn organisiert?
Ich hab da anfangs tatsächlich auch sehr, sehr gerungen, Menschen zu finden. Das war gar nicht so einfach. Ich hab mehrere Aufrufe gestartet, auch für die unterschiedlichen Bereiche. Einmal Software, einmal Karten erstellen und bauen. Das war auch ganz unterschiedlich, wie viel Rückmeldungen es da gab. Ich glaube, die meisten Menschen, die Karten gebaut haben, habe ich über einen Aufruf auf der internen Mailingliste gefunden. Und die meisten Menschen, die an der Software mitgebaut haben, haben wir über das Engelsystem, über einen Aufruf dort gefunden.
Und dann hatte die die Leute, aber wie habt ihr das dann untereinander organisiert? Hat dann jeder irgendwie eine Aufgabe bekommen und dann hat er halt gemacht, dann war es am Ende fertig oder gab es da ein tägliches Meeting? Oder wie kann man sich das vorstellen?
Tägliche Meetings zum Glück nicht. Wir haben ja großteils auch noch irgendwie alle einen Job, den wir nebenbei tun oder erledigen müssen oder machen müssen. Wir haben uns einmal in der Woche in der Regel so für eine Stunde oder für zwei Stunden in einer Telefonkonferenz getroffen und sonst nebenbei in einem Chat. Und natürlich irgendwie so die üblichen Entwicklungstools wie Git und Issues dort und so was, was man halt dann benutzt, um sich zu koordinieren.
So, dann stand also die Technik. Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen erstaunt, weil das klingt so, als sei es was total einfaches, 20 Leute miteinander zu kombinieren, die einfach so ein riesiges Projekt miteinander an den Start bringen und dann einfach über eine Code-Verteil-Plattform miteinander arbeiten. War das wirklich so einfach?
Es hat sich Gott sei Dank zusammengefunden, muss ich sagen. Jeder hat sich so um seine Teile angenommen. Und einmal in der Woche haben wir uns noch abgestimmt. Aber teilweise hat es natürlich auch, dann hat wieder mal Stress in der Arbeit gehabt, dann ist wieder ein Teil liegen geblieben und so weiter und so fort. Aber im Großen und Ganzen hat es dann einfach dazu gereicht, dass wir einfach alle so motiviert waren, das fertig zu bekommen für die Leute. Also in den letzten Tagen ist die Geschwindigkeit von der Feature-Implementierung so stark raufgeschossen, dass auf einmal alles funktioniert hat.
Ab wann war es denn wirklich fertig?
Also ich würde auch behaupten, das war auch während des Kongresses noch ein Work in Progress. Aber das hat, glaube ich, auch sehr, sehr viel von der Kongressstimmung ausgemacht. Weil wer schon mal auf so einem Real-Kongress war, der weiß auch, der Kongress ist nie fertig, sondern da wird bis zum letzten Tag, bis der Erbau beginnt, noch aufgebaut.
Also es gab auch wirklich einige Features, die irgendwie so am letzten Tag noch entstanden sind und die dann bis Nacht um fünf, als die Welt abgeschaltet wurde, dann noch hart ausgenutzt wurden. Also es war schon sehr spannend zum Teil.
Partizipation ist ja auch gerade einer der großen, ja, Stimmungsmacher auf Chaos-Events. Man kommt nicht auf ein fertiges Event. Man kommt auf ein Event, auf dem man alles noch anfassen und fördern darf und besser machen darf. Und das ist genau, worauf die Community Bock hat. Das ist natürlich auch klar, dass das vielleicht in anderen Communities nicht funktioniert hätte.
Inwiefern?
Naja, wenn noch wackelt. Ich glaube, es ist sehr üblich, ein fertiges Event hinzustellen und dass Menschen dann da hinkommen und staunen. Das ist in der Hacker-Community nicht der Fall. Und da kann man auch nicht davon ausgehen, dass die Leute die Sachen in Ruhe lassen. Ich glaube, diese Sachen, mit denen wir kopieren den Link aus der Adresseile im Browser, damit wir auf derselben Instanz in derselben Welt landen und uns unterhalten können, mit sowas muss man einfach rechnen, dass es passiert. Aber wir haben da natürlich auch das Glück, eine sehr freundliche Community zu haben, die bei sowas einfach gerne Dinge besser machen will und nicht kaputt machen möchte.
Aber das ist ja auch die, das ist die, na, das ist ja auch so sagen, das Ding in dieser Community, das aus der das Wort zervorschen kommt. Also im Sinne von, ha, eine neue Technik, lass uns doch mal gucken, ob sie kaputt geht, wenn ich das hier mache. Gab es damit auch ein Problem?
Relativ wenig, würde ich sagen. Es war eher so ein Fall von, Leute haben festgestellt, dass man Dinge tun kann und haben lustige Dinge damit gemacht. Es gab halt Maps, wo wirklich Leute sich verlieren konnten, weil sie permanent auf eine andere Map wieder draufgesprungen sind, weil es für diese Maps gibt es Sprungpunkte. Man kann von einer Map in die nächste springen und wieder zurück. Da gab es zum Teil so wirre Dinge, dass man eine Art Labyrinth hat, wo man durchlaufen musste. Am vierten Tag entstand das sogenannte Klonetzwerk, wo man durch die Klos in andere Maps springen konnte. So war es halt. Großartige Beispiele.
Zum zerspielen kann ich eine lustige Anekdote einwerfen. Und zwar hat das Zert irgendwann den sogenannten Cube gebaut. Und das kam leider nie dazu, das einmal auszuprobieren. Aber nach meinem Verständnis nach war das eben eine Art Labyrinth, durch die man durchlaufen musste und bestand anfangs aus 256 Karten. Und dann haben sich Nerds da angesetzt und haben das Computer basiert gelöst. Und dann dachte sich das Zert, hm, dann ist das ja noch zu einfach. Wir erhöhen auf 1024 Karten und haben sich damit im Endeffekt ihre eigene Instanz kaputt gespielt, weil die irgendwann auch einfach nicht mehr mit der Menge Karten klarkamen, die sie da drauf gespielt haben.
So, ich finde gerade den Gedanken ganz spannend, dass eine, sozusagen eine Technik oder ein Event auf dem Chaos, was sozusagen einen kreativen Auslass bietet, anscheinend dann wenig Motivation übrig lässt, um es kaputt zu machen. Das finde ich auch ganz spannend. Im Vorfeld hat mich auch die Frage erreicht, was denn da an Technik dahinter steckt. Also im Sinne nicht an Technik, sondern an Hardware, weil so eine Welt muss ja irgendwie auch betrieben werden. Wie viel Rechner, Server, ich weiß nicht, was man da an Zahlen, an Kapazitätsangaben machen kann, aber was habt ihr dafür gebraucht, um dieses Ding, wie es da war, zu betreiben?
Also im Endeffekt haben wir kleine Instanzen mit einem Prozessor und zwei GB RAM für jedes Frontend und Backend verwendet. Also Frontend war das, wo man hingesurft ist, Backend war alles, was eine Instanz gehabt hat. Also die Bewegungsdaten-Austausch ist übers Backend gelaufen. Die Karten und die Webseite sind übers Frontend gelaufen. Also da haben wir 405 Server im Endausbau gehabt, am letzten Tag glaube ich, oder 411, die dann halt die unterschiedlichsten Assemblies, Karten und sonst irgendwas bedient haben.
Hab ich es gerade richtig gehört, 411 verschiedene Server?
Also ich kann mal Statistik, ich hab tatsächlich mal Screenshots gemacht während der Veranstaltung von den Work-Adventure-Transitions. Da hatten wir deploy 294, 70 deploying und 42 DNS. Es steckte schon ordentlich was hinter und ich glaube, am Ende waren es noch ein paar mehr als das.
Und wie viel Bandbreite ist nötig, um sowas zu betreiben?
Wir haben zwischenzeitlich, also wir haben das Ganze über unsere GitLab-Installation deployed. Dort wurden die Images für die einzelnen Server generiert und von dort dann auf die Server deployed und ausgespielt. Und da haben wir zwischenzeitlich mit über 3 Gigabit pro Sekunde Images deployed.
Okay, ich muss mal durchfragen, wo kommt das her? Da haben ja sozusagen wahrscheinlich nicht irgendwie 100.000 Leute ihren Rechner zu Hause hinter dem DSL angemacht und es hat sich dann irgendwie zusammen gekloppt, sondern die müssen ja irgendwie stehen, das kostet doch auch, oder?
Die Welt war großteils bei Hetzner gehostet und wir hatten da im Vorfeld mal mit Hetzner gesprochen und die haben uns da ein bisschen gesponsort. Das heißt, im Endeffekt war alles, was wir für diese Welt an Instanzen gebraucht haben, eigentlich durch dieses Sponsoring abgedeckt.
Der Haupttraffic war auch nicht ins Internet, Gott sei Dank, sondern intern, also wenn wir einen neuen Server aufgebaut haben, dann haben wir praktisch die Software natürlich ziehen müssen. Da das Docker Image ist, also praktisch komplette Betriebssysteme waren, ist da auch ein entsprechender Aufwand dahinter gewesen.
So, dann haben wir also die Software ganz grob. Ich glaube, die noch genauer zu erklären, würde wahrscheinlich hier das Verständnis ein bisschen sprengen und wissen jetzt auch, dass da unfassbare Mengen von Hardware an den Start kamen. Das war ja zugangsbeschränkt, oder? Das hing doch irgendwie an so einem Ticket dran, oder konnte da jeder mitmachen?
Das ist richtig. Wir haben uns relativ früh entschlossen, dass wir wahrscheinlich Tickets verteilen müssen, auch weil andere Veranstaltungen so ein bisschen von Trollen überrannt worden sind. Also wenn man alles aufmacht, dann wird es plötzlich sehr voll. Und die Leute, die sich dann da treffen, sind nicht immer die Freundlichsten oder versuchen halt zu stören. Das Problem hatten wir an anderen Stellen dann auch, aber da wir unsere Tickets entschieden hatten, hat das Ganze ein bisschen abgefedert und andere Bereiche als die Welt betroffen.
Wir waren auch deswegen auf dieses Ticket-Ding draufgesprungen, um ein bisschen abzuschätzen zu können, was für Infrastruktur wir überhaupt brauchen. Es skaliert ja nicht unendlich, auch wenn es irgendwie in der Cloud hängt, wie viele im Vorfeld behauptet haben, muss ja alles entsprechend gecoded werden, dass es auch die Hardware mitmacht, die wir am Ende da stehen haben.
Was waren das Bestöraktionen, von denen du gerade gesprochen hast? Was ist da passiert?
Hauptsächlich DDoS auf DNS-Server und die Infrastruktur, die man eben frei erreichen konnte. Und dann teilweise auch, wohl recht strategisch, versucht, bestimmte Knotenpunkte wegzuedoßen und anzugreifen und das Netzwerk anzugucken. Da hatten wir aber dann auch sehr fähige Leute dahinter, die sich im Schichtsystem rund um die U-Rung gekümmert haben, dass alles weiterläuft.
So, dann gab es also diese ganze Technik, die da stand, und dann, also ja, es ist bis zum Schluss gebastelt worden, aber es gab dann irgendwann den Tag 0 oder Tag 1, wo das Ganze aufgemacht wurde. Wie ist das denn angenommen worden?
Also dadurch, dass wir gerade am Anfang noch ein kleines bisschen technische Probleme, sage ich einfach mal, hatten bzw. noch nicht ganz fertig waren einfach und sich das ein bisschen verzögert hat, am Anfang eher ein kleines bisschen schleppend, weil ich meine, wenn man das dann irgendwie das erste Mal aufruft und das geht alles nicht, oder was heißt das geht alles nicht, es geht vieles noch nicht oder man fliegt immer mal wieder raus, war das glaube ich am Anfang ein bisschen gedämpft. Das haben wir aber sehr sehr schnell in den Griff gekriegt, auch dank einer Nachtschicht. Und dann hat sich das glaube ich sehr sehr schnell eingespielt. Spätestens wenn man das zweite Mal reingeguckt hat und das dann doch alles viel flüssiger lief, wurde das dann sehr sehr schnell angenommen und auch sehr sehr schnell einfach entdeckt, wie viel man damit machen kann. Also auch Assemblies, die am Anfang vielleicht eher so eine sporadische Karte hatten, haben dann auf einmal gemerkt, was damit eigentlich geht, wenn man dann auch sieht, was die anderen gebastelt haben und dann ist es zumindest meinem Gefühl nach dann doch eher explodiert.
Man muss zu dem Time-Frame natürlich auch noch sagen, wir haben im Vorfeld nicht unfassbar intern, wie sagt man, ja jetzt fällt mir das Wort nicht ein verdammt, wir haben dann extrem darauf hingewiesen, dass wir einen Work-Adventure nutzen werden. Was dazu geführt hat, dass viele wirklich erst an Tag 0 bzw. 1, als die World dann hochgefahren ist, überhaupt erst mal wussten, was sie zu tun hatten. Was sehr stark dazu geführt hat, dass vielleicht so Tag 2, 3 überhaupt erst so richtig alles ausgebaut wurde.
Ich glaube, die Leute haben sich da auch einfach gegenseitig inspiriert. Die ersten Maps, wo sich ein paar Leute wirklich gut hingesetzt haben, die Features voll ausgenutzt haben, haben da glaube ich einfach sehr viele Leute inspiriert, selbst kreativ zu werden.
Vor allem haben einige Leute während der Veranstaltung noch Git gelernt. Und das waren gar nicht unbedingt Menschen, die im technischen Bereich arbeiten, sondern auch Menschen aus dem künstlerischen oder schriftstellerischen Bereich. Und die damit jetzt einfach ein tolles Tool für sich entdeckt haben, für ihre persönliche Arbeit.
Heißt das, wenn man Assemblies bauen will oder wenn man sozusagen Elemente auf dieser Karte verändern will, muss man programmieren können? Oder gibt es auch sozusagen so eine Art visuellen Editor Minecraft-mäßig, kann ich da Klötzchen irgendwo hinsetzen und Dinge selber pixeln?
Der Editor für die ganzen Karten ist rein grafisch eigentlich. Also das ist so ein bisschen, man schiebt mit der Maus Kartenelemente zusammen. Aber um das Ganze dann eben in sein Assembly oder in die Welt zu bekommen, musste man Git benutzen. Das war einfach der Hintergrund, dass wir uns überlegt hatten, dass das wahrscheinlich, das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen ITler getrübt, diese Sicht, das Einfachste und das Beste sein wird, um Karten jederzeit aktualisieren zu können, dass wir von unseren Servern aus einfach immer dieses Git ziehen und da die neueste Version auschecken und dann die Assemblies eben dort einfach ihre Änderungen reinpacken. Was natürlich auf der anderen Seite aber dazu geführt hat, dass Menschen, die Karten einreichen wollten, Git ein bisschen bedienen mussten. Das war mit eines der schönsten Momente eigentlich, dass ich dann aus unserer Feedbackrunde mitgenommen habe, dass dort erzählt wurde, dass eben auch Menschen, die sonst überhaupt nichts mit IT zu tun haben, dadurch Git gelernt haben und das in der Zwischenzeit auch relativ flüssig wohl bedienen können.
Und gibt das diese Software nicht her, dass man auch im laufenden Betrieb quasi die Welt, in der man gerade ist, verändert? Oder habt ihr euch konkret sozusagen dafür entschieden, dass es immer diesen Zwischen- stritt braucht, bevor man was macht?
Es geht einfach darum, dass wir auf unseren Servern die Daten von irgendwo laden mussten. Und Git war einfach die einfachste Möglichkeit für uns, diese Daten von irgendwo runterzuladen.
Nee, das meine ich gar nicht, sondern ich meinte, gibt es, also diese Software, die das basiert, hat die die Möglichkeit, dass wenn ich mit meinem Männchen da rumlaufe, dass ich sozusagen live die Änderungen mache.
Nein, das gibt es einfach nicht her. Also vor allem keine Änderungen, die andere Leute auch sehen. Also wir haben die Animationen eingebaut, die Audiosachen haben wir reingepatcht im Vorfeld des Kongresses. Aber Synchronisationssachen, wo praktisch ein User etwas macht und ein anderer User darauf eine Animation sieht, das gibt die Software nicht her.
Hat euch irgendwas, was Menschen da gemacht haben, überrascht? Oder ist das alles im Rahmen dessen geblieben, wo ihr dachtet, okay, ja, das war ja sozusagen klar, dass man das mit des Haftes auch machen kann?
Na, gerne auch du. Ich wollte eigentlich nur sagen, dass mir zwar bewusst war, was technisch geht, ich war aber einfach völlig von der Kreativität, die die Menschen da reingesteckt haben, überrascht oder auch geflasht eigentlich. Und das war viel, viel imposanter, viel, viel mehr, als ich mir jemals vorgestellt hätte, dass damit passiert.
Also es gibt so ein schönes Beispiel, die Moin Assembly, das ist so eine Zusammenstellung von norddeutschen Hacker-Spaces. Die haben virtuell Lübeck nachgebaut. Also wirklich so eine ganze Map mit ganz vielen alten wunderschönen Hansehäusern. Und mir wurde gesagt, dass sie wohl so tatsächlich extra Teilsets gekauft haben gegen Geld, damit die Fenster besonders schön aussehen in den Gebäuden. Wir haben auch echt, ich glaube, eine Stunde oder zwei habe ich mit ein paar Leuten aus dem Team irgendwie auf dieser Map verbracht. Und das war unfassbar großartig. Weil man konnte dann wirklich auf so kleinen Burgmauern rumlaufen. Und dieser Detailreichtum, der hat mich zum Teil echt weggeballert, was das angeht.
Wir haben uns ja unter anderem deshalb für Pixel-Grafik entschieden, weil sie relativ leicht zugänglich ist im Vergleich zu zum Beispiel 3D. Das war die Hoffnung, dass möglichst viele Menschen mitmachen können und was Eigenes einreichen können oder eben fertige Sachen finden.
Die Bandbreite von dem, was es gab, war auch einfach riesig. Wie Katti gerade schon erzählt hat, irgendwie Lübeck relativ detailgetreu nachgebaut. Bis hin dann auch zu völlig abstrakten Karten, die eigentlich gar nichts mehr mit Dingen, die es in der Realität gibt, zu tun haben. Die vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr wirklich an ein 2D-Spiel oder so erinnern. So ein weißer Hintergrund und ab und zu tauchen irgendwo irgendwelche Ausgänge auf, die nur kurz aufblinken, die aber eigentlich gar keine Ausgänge sind. Eine abstrakte Zeichnung, ein Kunstwerk, auf dem man herumlaufen kann. Die Bandbreite war einfach riesig an Dingen, die es gab.
Gab es da nicht auch so eine Matrix-Map, wo man irgendwie auf das Telefon steigen musste? Und dann gab es auch wirklich Spaces, die haben sich wirklich über die ganzen vier Tage ständig verändert und man hatte immer wieder neue Sachen, die man entdecken konnte. Ein schönes Beispiel war, finde ich persönlich, die Küche im Heaven, wo dann irgendwann, ich glaube an Tag drei, anfing der Topf über zu kochen und alles war voll mit grüner Soße. Da war wirklich immer was Neues. Also egal, wann man da reinkam, ist es immer irgendwas Verrücktes passiert.
Auch die Chaos-Zone mit der Abriss-Party am Ende war grenzgenial, meiner Meinung nach.
Stimmt, das fand ich beim Abbau sehr schön. Diese ganzen Teile, die dann entstanden sind, mit Paletten und Dinge, die abgebaut werden, die Portale, die weggepackt werden, das fand ich sehr schön.
Also da haben sie sagen, Leute, die Mühe gemacht, extra Grafiken dafür zu entwerfen, um zu symbolisieren, dass die Welt jetzt abgebaut wird.
Die Welt ist auch immer ein kleines bisschen mehr zerbrochen, wenn man das vielleicht so sagen kann, als das auf den Abbau bzw. als das auf das Ende zuging. Also man hat dann vielleicht irgendwie mal ein Teil von einem Portal gefehlt, dann ist irgendwo der Weg kaputt gegangen, dann sind auf einmal die Dächer von irgendwelchen Dingen verschwunden. Also so wie das tatsächlich beim Abbau ist. Das war großartig.
Und die Menschen haben eine Geschichte erzählt mit der Welt, die sie da zur Verfügung hatten, indem sie in der Versionierungssoftware neue Daten hochgeladen haben. Das ist schon beeindruckend. Also das ist tatsächlich eine Sache, mit der ich weniger gerechnet habe, obwohl es mir hätte klar sein müssen, dass so was passieren kann.
Also noch mal ein bisschen darauf zurückzukommen. Also mich hat gewundert, was alles erzählt worden ist mit den doch einfachen Mitteln, die wir gehabt haben. Also die Animationen, der Sound. Und da sind Welten entstanden mit so viel kreativer Energie dahinter. Das war einfach faszinierend für mich.
Wo ist denn eigentlich, das wollte ich gerade fragen, wo ist denn der Sound hergekommen? Weil bei solchen Projekten habe ich, also zumindest vom Klischee her, manchmal den Verdacht, dass, naja, es wird die Technik hingestellt und dann wird die Pixel-Grafik gemacht. Da findet sich vielleicht noch mal ein Designer, da versucht man sich auch selber dran. Aber Sound ist so was, das fällt dann manchmal hinten runter. Habt ihr da auch sozusagen ExpertInnen gehabt, die sich darum gekümmert haben, oder wie ist der Sound in die Welt gekommen?
Der Sound ist tatsächlich gar nicht so, also wir hatten sehr, sehr wenig mit irgendwie Sounds zu tun. Wir haben die Möglichkeit eingebaut, dass man Soundfiles einbinden kann. Und der Rest ist komplett durch die Assemblies entstanden, die dann von so ganz banalen Sachen, wie irgendwie man läuft irgendwo vorbei und im Hintergrund hört man Mateflaschen umfallen, was so instant ein, ich fühle mich auf dem Congress-Feeling, zumindest bei mir triggert, bis hin zu, dass irgendwie Soundfiles teilweise selbst erstellt wurden. Also da haben wir sehr, sehr wenig vorgegeben. Wir haben die technischen Möglichkeiten dafür geschaffen und der Rest ist durch die Community entstanden.
ExpertInnen hat das Chaos ja eigentlich für alles. Manchmal ahnt man gar nicht, dass man sie hat. Und dann tauchen sie irgendwo auf und machen tolle Dinge. Und ich glaube, das war an der Stelle auch so. Wir haben die Lounge geplant und den Musikstream der Lounge natürlich auch in der Welt in der Lounge-Karte gehabt. Da haben sich also Menschen zum Feiern treffen können. Und ansonsten gab es eben die Möglichkeit dieser kurzen Soundschnipsel, die hochgeladen werden konnten. Und das waren dann teilweise irgendwelche schönen Design-Baselines oder eben mehr so Sounddesign-mäßig irgendwelche. Objekte, die sich bewegen.
Auch zum Beispiel tatsächlich auch aus der Heaven-Kitchen. Das war halt wirklich so diese Kantinen-Stimmung. Also man hat sich wirklich so eine Schlange anstellen können. Und man ist dann vorgegangen zum Befehl. Und man hatte halt so dieses Teller-Klappern und diese ganze Soundkulisse, wie wenn man einfach da in der Schlange steht.
Kann ich mir wirklich sehr gut vorstellen. Und ich finde auch ganz spannend, dass die Geschichten, die ihr alle erzählt, mit dem Umgang, mit der Software zu tun haben. Und es gibt ja aber zwei Sachen, die zumindest vordergründig dazu gedient haben, um die körperliche Begegnung jetzt nicht zu ersetzen, aber sozusagen eine Analogen zu bieten. Und das eine, da will ich gleich noch drüber sprechen, ist eben diese persönliche Begegnung. Und das andere war ja auch, dass die Idee schon auch war, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, Assemblies sind da, also Gruppen von Menschen, die sich normalerweise auf dem Kongress ausstellen, haben dann da sozusagen so eine Map und können da Dinge tun, um auch wirklich sozusagen in Kontakt zu kommen. Ich habe davon, ich war in der Welt nicht so fürchterlich lang unterwegs, ich habe nur in diversen Timelines mitbekommen, dass da sich beklagt wurde, dass die Assemblies an sich dann doch oft sehr leer waren. Also im Sinne von, dass sie zwar da waren, aber das dann keiner da, den man dann antraff. Ist das sozusagen, habe ich da so ein verzerrtes Bild geliefert gekommen? Oder ist dieser ursprüngliche Zweck dann irgendwann hinten runtergefallen, weil die Spielbarkeit oder die Verspieltheit so hoch war?
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass es hinten rübergefallen ist. Ich glaube, es war eher der Fall, dass Leute viel anderes erleben konnten. Also es ist ein bisschen wie beim Kongress selbst. Also ganz ehrlich, wenn ich auf dem Kongress bin, bin ich relativ wenig in meiner eigenen Assembly, sondern bewege mich irgendwo anders hin. Und ich hatte irgendwie das Gefühl, das war bei der RC3 nicht groß anders. Und es gab auch Spaces, die haben sich wirklich eins zu eins nachgebaut. Also ich komme aus Bochum aus dem Labor. Wir haben unseren Space eins zu eins nachgebaut. Und es ist auch passiert, dass Leute aus extern da waren und sich angeguckt haben so, ach, wie sieht denn euer Space aus? Ist ja total schön. Aber das passiert natürlich auch im normalen Kongress vielleicht auch gar nicht unbedingt so, weil man hat halt eine schlichte Assembly und man setzt sich halt an seinen Tisch.
Ich glaube für mich der Hauptgrund, warum das so ist, ist, es ist einfach so, dass man offline geht. Also man ist nicht 24-7 in der Online-Welt. Man geht einfach mal offline. Man geht nicht in seine eigene Assembly zurück. Wenn man am Kongress ist, dann setzt man sich zum Ausruhen vielleicht einmal zum Tisch in der eigenen Assembly. Und wenn man vorbeikommt, dann ist immer wer da, weil sich gerade wer ausruht oder sonst irgendwas passiert in der Assembly. In der Online-Welt geht man halt einfach mal offline und ist dann nicht verfügbar, unter Anführungszeichen. Ich glaube, das ist das Bild, was den Unterschied macht.
Ich glaube auch, was Roang gerade sagt, das ist mit so einer der Hauptgründe, dass man vielleicht auch gar nicht so viel Zeit in dieser Online-Welt verbracht hat, wie man das auf einem Kongress tun würde. Und natürlich muss man auch sagen, wir hatten über 200 Assembly-Karten. Das war auch einfach eine Riesenwelt und hat sich da tatsächlich ein bisschen verlaufen, glaube ich. Es gab immer wieder ein paar Assemblies, wo es geklumpt hat, wo immer relativ viel los war. Der Rest hat sich aber, glaube ich, tatsächlich ein bisschen verlaufen. Ich weiß nicht, wie man das das nächste Mal vielleicht besser machen würde, weil man will ja auch nicht sagen, hey, baut mal nicht so viele Karten oder baut mal nur jedes zweite Assembly eine Karte, damit das weniger ist. Sondern man will ja schon allen die Möglichkeit geben, Karten beizusteuern und gerne auch viel. Ich glaube, man muss dann auch einfach nur damit rechnen, dass das halt auch mal weniger ist.
Ich überlege gerade, ob ich ein repräsentatives Bild abgeben kann von dem, was ich da gesehen habe oder wie viele Menschen ich begegnet habe, weil ich immer nur Nachtschichten hatte während der Veranstaltung. Aber auch da war relativ viel los. Ich hatte das Gefühl, die Menschen waren dann unterwegs, um sich andere Assemblies anzugucken. Manche sind nur durchgeruscht, manche sind dann irgendwo hängen geblieben. Und tatsächlich habe ich auch mehrere Menschen getroffen, mitten in der Nacht, die ich gut kannte. Auch durchaus aus meiner eigenen Stadt, aber niemals in den Assembleräumen, in denen ich es erwartet hätte. Sondern die haben sich eben auch was angeguckt. Und insofern auf jeden Fall wie beim Kongress. Man trifft sich irgendwo auf dem Flur, aber nicht zwangsläufig da, wo man suchen würde.
Und auf der anderen Seite darf man noch nicht vergessen, dass die Assemblies, die ihre Maps gebaut haben, die haben sie ja nicht nur für dieses eine Event gebaut. Also es gibt ganz viele Spaces, die ihre Instanz selber betreiben, um halt sozusagen so eine virtuelle Entsprechung ihres Spaces zu haben, solange der gerade zu ist.
Die andere Sache, die ihr eingerichtet habt, die ich jetzt schon ein paar Mal erwähnt habe, ist ja dieses, wenn man mit einem Avatar, also jemand anders hinläuft, geht die Webcam auf und das Mikrofon an und man kann sich da wirklich treffen. Ich hab das, weil ich manchmal so bin, ja, ich glaub mich ja einen, guck mal was geht, ich hab mich total erschreckt, als das zum ersten Mal passiert ist, hab's dann schnell ausgemacht. Wie war denn die allgemeine Reaktion darauf?
Ich glaub anfangs auch so ein bisschen Verhalten, ich glaub in den ersten Momenten ging's den meisten so wie dir, weil wir sind ja dann auch vielleicht, ich geh da jetzt mal von mir aus, alle ein bisschen online-paranoid. Und ich zumindest zeig mich jetzt nicht unbedingt so direkt gerne in einer Webcam-Fremden gegenüber oder so. Auf einem Kongress trifft man sich ja aber natürlich auch in real. Und man gewöhnt sich da ehrlich gesagt sehr, sehr schnell an, oder zumindest hab ich das getan. Und dann war's auch überhaupt kein Problem mehr, einfach total random Menschen in der Welt zu begegnen, mit denen kurz irgendwie in der Webcam zu sprechen, vielleicht ein kurzes Hi, und dann guckt man, ob man irgendwie was zu reden, ein Thema findet, oder ob man sich gerade nur zufällig begegnet ist und eigentlich beide in eine andere Richtung wollten. Sagt man, ich wollte eigentlich gerade dahin, dahin. Und das war aber auch eigentlich eine coole Erfahrung, wie ich fand, dass dann nicht einfach nur vorbeigehuscht wurde, sondern sobald diese Webcam eben aufging, sagte man dann auch, ich bin eigentlich gerade auf dem Weg woanders hin, ich hab gerade gar keine Zeit und ist dann erst weitergelaufen und nicht einfach direkt.
Also ich hatte tatsächlich ein Erlebnis, da stand ich irgendwie ziemlich beliebig, weil ich gerade Langeweile hatte in der Lounge rum und plötzlich poppte das Videofenster auf und ich stellte so fest so, hä? Und da traf ich dann halt eine Freundin aus Berlin wieder, die ich vor zwei Jahren das letzte Mal gesehen hab. So total beliebig innerhalb von 1000 anderen Leuten, die da gerade unterwegs waren. Und wir haben uns dann tatsächlich einfach mal 10 Minuten unterhalten.
Ich hab, ich hab noch, ich denke jetzt gerade noch drüber nach, was denn da so anders ist. Und ich glaube, tatsächlich ist es auch dieses nicht an jemanden vorbeilaufen können, was mich wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen erschreckt hat, weil auf einem MeetSpace-Kongress kannst du also sagen an Leuten einfach vorbeigehen. Und hier ist ja ein Vorbeigehen aber verbunden mit diesem Video-Fans, das ist ja im Prinzip schon in Hallo. Ich finde aber sehr witzig, dass sich diese, wie Psy gerade erzählt hat, neue Kommunikationsformen oder Kommunikationsritual entwickelt hat, dann zu sagen, tschüssi.
Wir haben ja auch bewusst irgendwann festgestellt, dass es vielleicht gut ist, dass man es auch abschalten kann. Also wir dürfen nicht vergessen, dass auch auf so einem Kongress Leute aus dem Spektrum unterwegs sind, die da vielleicht nicht unbedingt Bock drauf haben, dass man mit irgendwelchen Leuten sprechen zu müssen. Oder dieses Gefühl zu haben, man müsste mit denen sprechen. Sondern eben auch diese Funktion zu haben, ich gehe jetzt einfach nur durch und keiner kann mich ansprechen, was auch völlig in Ordnung ist, weil das passiert auf einem normalen Kongress genauso.
Ist auch eins der Feature, dass die Entwickler noch nachreichen wollen, bzw. vielleicht haben sie das auch schon eingebaut. Und zwar, dass diese Gruppenunterhaltung oder dieses Proximity-Feature, wie es tatsächlich heißt, erst dann passiert, wenn man stehen bleibt. Das heißt, wenn man sich einfach nur irgendwo entlang bewegt, dann geht nicht mehr die Webcam auf. Das ist, glaube ich, einfach so ein Ding, was man eben auch erst lernen musste.
Also es war sozusagen eine rudimentäre Technologie oder ein rudimentäres Feature, dem noch gefeilt werden muss.
Ich glaube, es war einfach eine Erfahrung, die man noch sammeln musste und aus der Erfahrung dann Dinge verbessern.
Es ist, glaube ich, auch einfach so, wir haben ja mit den Entwicklern mehrere Chats gehabt, auch ein Interview am Kongress, dass wir so ziemlich das größte Deployment für die Software implementiert haben. Also sie waren überrascht, dass wir so viele Leute auf den Instanzen hatten. Also ich glaube, das ist einfach etwas, was auch mit der Menge an Leuten einfach viel schlimmer geworden ist. Weil wenn man durch eine Gruppe von 20 Leuten gelaufen ist, dann hat man halt 20 Mal das Bing-Bing-Bing-Bing gehabt.
Von diesem Geräusch werde ich irgendwann noch träumen, glaube ich.
Habt ihr noch so ein paar Statistikzahlen? Also wie viele Leute waren da? Wie viel Stunden Video-Chat wurde sich unterhalten? Oder irgendwie noch, um noch abzubilden? Weil wir wissen ja sozusagen, es war eine große Rechenkraft, die da stand. Und die finde ich in keinem Verhältnis zu stehen. Du siehst so diese relativ kleine Anzahl von Leuten, die da das Grundgruß zumindest gebaut haben. Wisst ihr denn, wie viele Besucher ihr hattet?
Also wir haben, glaube ich, einen Top-Wert von irgendwas bei 1600 Leuten gleichzeitig in der World. Und das halte ich schon für ziemlich viel, ehrlich gesagt. Wir haben tatsächlich mit mehr gerechnet. Also es war deutlich höher skaliert eigentlich. Aber 1600 finde ich schon eine ganz schöne Ansage. Zumal wir auch eine Woche hatten, wo normalerweise Leute arbeiten gehen und Kinder zu Hause haben und vielleicht auch ganz viel anderes noch zu tun hätten.
Und was wir natürlich nicht wissen, ist, wie viele Leute sich insgesamt eingeloggt haben. Weil, na also 1600 peak, aber wie viel verteilt über den Tag, wie viele Unique-Visitor, das wissen wir einfach nicht. Wir wissen auch nicht, wie viele Stunden Video, aber wir wissen, welche Datenmenge, weil das eben zum großen Teil, man sitzt daheim hinter irgendwie einem Router und NAT, und dann muss das eben über sogenannte Stunt-Server geproxied werden, und die haben wiederum ungefähr 3 bis 4 Terabyte Datenvolumen weitergeleitet.
Insgesamt oder pro Stunde?
Nein, nein, insgesamt. Also in der Welt dieses Proximity-Feature, die Unterhaltung davon, das hat in Summe so 3 bis 4 Terabyte Daten erzeugt.
Wobei da ja auch noch die Jitsis dahinter waren.
Die was?
Jitsi ist eine Videochat-Plattform in Open Source. Jitsi wurde eingesetzt an Stellen in der Welt, wo mehr als vier Personen aufeinander treffen sollten. Zum Beispiel an der Bar in der Lounge, wenn man sich treffen wollte, konnte man da mit einer größeren Gruppe hin, und dann ging auf der rechten Seite vom Browser so ein größeres Fenster auf, und da hatte man dann eben eine Jitsi-Instanz laufen, wo man ganz viele Video-Audio-Chats mit Menschen offen hatte, und dann hatte man eine große Konferenz. Da kann man in dem Workadventure eben so Zonen für konfigurieren.
Also Jitsi eben so eine normale, sag ich mal, Videocore-Software. Das heißt aber, dieses Proximity, dieses Annäherungsfeature, da war das Audio und Video dann nicht ausgelagert an externer Software, sondern das ist tatsächlich dann ein interner Teil von diesem Workadventure.
Genau, das ist im Endeffekt einfach Peer-to-Peer-Audio und Video zwischen den Teilnehmern, zwischen der Gruppe, die sich da trifft. Und das passiert auch nicht durch Jitsi, sondern das macht das Workadventure an sich.
So, also dann haben wir diese riesige virtuelle Welt mit tausenden Leuten und mehreren hundert Rechenkapazitäten. Und einem Kongress, jetzt muss ich das doch mal fragen. Das ist eine kleine Schleife. Und zwar, ich fand das, ich bin, nee, ich muss es einfach fragen. War das jetzt ein Chaos-Communication-Kongress oder war das ein Remote-Chaos-Experience?
Oh, da machst du einen Fass auf. Also im Vorfeld, wie gesagt, es gab sehr viele Gegenstimmen gegen uns. Gegen die Veranstaltung überhaupt. Sehr viel Sorge, dass das keine gute Veranstaltung wird. Ja, und daraus geboren eben, das ist nicht der 37C3, der 37C3 wird auf jeden Fall das nächste Präsenz-Event sein, wann das immer stattfinden wird. Und wir brauchten neuen Namen und da sind wir eben bei der RC3 gelandet.
Das war auch tatsächlich einer der Vorschläge, der sich quasi von Anfang an durchgezogen hat. Das war mehr oder weniger einer der ersten Namensvorschläge, die wir hatten.
Ich moderiere das Chaosradio, aber bin ja trotzdem in vielen Dingen ein Außenstehender und mich befremdet das ein bisschen, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Weil 37C3 der Herzen, definitiv. Weiß gar nicht, was es dazu zu überlegen gibt.
Getreu unserem Motto, es ist, was du draus machst.
Also ich bleibe dabei. Also der 37C3 ist dann auch irgendwann dem Ende entgegengegangen. Und dann habe ich sozusagen mal, ja, mit dieser Welt, was wird denn, bleibt die für immer da? Ich vermute mal nein, aber was ist denn daraus geworden? Es gab ja einen Abbau. Ist die jetzt komplett weg? Oder gibt es irgendwo eine Archivversion, die man besuchen kann?
TeilnehmerInnen haben während des Kongresses Dinge da mitgemacht und haben natürlich auch angefangen, Dinge zu skripten. Und neben z.B. sowas hatten wir jetzt noch gar nicht. Es gab so Badges in der Welt, oder kamen dann sehr, sehr spät in der Welt, so kleine Abzeichen, die man verliehen bekommen hat, wenn man über gewisse Bereiche gelaufen ist z.B. Und haben sich natürlich auch Menschen hingesetzt und haben das einfach mal automatisiert, gecrawlt, um die alle aus den Kartendateien rauszulesen. Und genauso gab es eben auch einfach Menschen, die sich hingesetzt haben und diese ganzen Karten einmal gecrawlt haben. Und da gibt es jetzt ein Git Repository, ich glaube bei GitHub. Da liegen einerseits die Karten, also das sind einfach nur JSON-Files, die beschreiben, wie diese Karten aussehen. Und dann in der Regel auch nochmal ein Rendering davon als Grafik, wie diese Karte denn aussah. Das heißt, wenn man einfach im Hintergrund dieses Work-Adventure wieder aufsetzt, dann kann man die ganzen Karten einfach wieder drauf werfen und im Endeffekt die Welt, wie sie war, wieder auferstehen lassen.
Zumindest zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt, ne?
Also wie ein Snapshot, wie eine Fotografie, die man sich dann bewegen kann. Ich hab die ganzen Fachbegriffe jetzt erstmal nicht hinterfragt, weil es sind halt sozusagen technische Dinge, die, die, die man, die, die sich damit auskönnen, sozusagen was damit anfangen können, die jetzt in der Tiefe zu erklären, würde wahrscheinlich zu weit führen. Und ich will sozusagen das noch ein bisschen ausweiten und fragen, wenn ich jetzt selber sowas will, also nicht die RC3 World zum, zum neuen Leben erwecken, sondern ich möchte selber so ein kleines Ding mir bauen, was brauch ich dafür und was muss ich dafür können?
Also nur um Karten zu gestalten?
Nee, nee, also nicht um Karten zu gestalten, sondern ich fand das geil, was da auf dem Kongress passiert ist. Und ich möchte jetzt sozusagen so ein Ding, ich möchte so eine Welt für mich haben, für mein Team, für meine Familie, für meinen Freundeskreis, was auch immer. Ich möchte sozusagen einfach so eine kleine Welt mit, die sozusagen so funktioniert wie die Chaoswelt, aber nicht die ist.
Also wir haben gesehen, dass die Welten recht wenig Leistung eigentlich brauchen. Vor allem in der Sache, die wir eingesetzt haben. Die Features sind jetzt mittlerweile ziemlich viele wieder im Workadventure zurückgelandet. Ein paar Sachen natürlich nicht, wie die Badges, weil die waren praktisch für den Kongress speziell gecodet. Aber Audio-Animationen, die sind jetzt gerade dabei oder sind schon im Upstream gelandet, also in der Work Machine, na, in der Coding Machine Workadventure Version. Auf ihrer GitHub-Seite gibt es auch eine Anleitung mit Docker-Files, die man verwenden kann, um sich das selbst aufzusetzen. Also was braucht man dafür? Wissen, wie Docker funktioniert. Und ein bisschen wissen, wie man praktisch so eine Website hostet. Also wie man die verfügbar macht und wo man die verfügbar machen kann.
Okay, aber sagen, wenn ich sowas zum Beispiel zuhause machen will, dann reicht ein normaler Rechner. Das hat dir am Anfang auch gesagt, dass ein einzelner Rechner gar nicht so viel Leistung haben muss.
Also für kleine Instanzen, für ein Team bis, sag ich mal, 50 Leute, reicht ein ganz einfacher Rechner.
Okay, dann könntet ihr vielleicht mir nach der Sendung noch die Links geben und dann können wir die ja in die Show Notes schreiben, dass die Menschen, die sich dafür interessieren, das vielleicht nachvollziehen können oder selber mal bauen können. Da scheint es ja tatsächlich ein paar Möglichkeiten zu geben. Das ist super. Wie ist denn jetzt die Zukunft sozusagen? Also es gibt zwei offensichtliche Fragen. Die eine offensichtliche Frage ist, naja, irgendwie zwischen den Jahren 2021, 2022, Pandemie vorbei, vielleicht eher nicht. Würdet ihr sowas noch mal machen? Oder war das ein One-Shot?
Also mit dem Team, das wir jetzt hatten auf jeden Fall noch mal, so gefühlsmäßig, ob wir es noch mal machen müssen. Uns wären natürlich alle die Präsenzversion deutlich lieber. Wir würden auch lieber alle Menschen wieder in den Arm nehmen können. Aber wenn es nicht geht, gucken wir uns das noch mal an.
Also wir haben auch tatsächlich gestern so ein bisschen so den Abschluss gemacht von allen Teams und ganz ehrlich, da jetzt schon eine Entscheidung treffen zu wollen, das ist unrealistisch. Also da müssen wir jetzt echt ein bisschen gucken, abwarten und im Zweifelsfall halt irgendwann loslegen.
Aber völlig unabhängig dessen, ob es jetzt ein Präsenz-Event geben wird oder nicht, gab es bereits Stimmen, die einfach gesagt haben, egal, ob wir uns in Zukunft wieder in Präsenz treffen oder nicht, wir wollen weiterhin in Zukunft so eine Welt nebenbei haben, weil die erlaubt auch einfach vielen Menschen, die jetzt zum Beispiel aus welchen Gründen auch immer, nicht an einem Präsenz-Event teilnehmen können, dass sie doch irgendwie an dem Event partizipieren können. Und müssen wir mal schauen, wie man das vielleicht kombinieren kann. Aber es gibt auf jeden Fall Stimmen, die sagen, wir wollen das, egal was kommt, auch in Zukunft haben.
Das wäre nämlich tatsächlich meine nächste Frage gewesen, ob man sowas verstetigt, weil es eben genau, was du gerade gesagt hast, eine Möglichkeit bietet, dass man dabei sein kann, ohne dabei sein zu können. Na gut, es bleibt spannend. Haben wir noch irgendwas vergessen?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Wir könnten bestimmt noch stundenlang Erfahrungen aus dieser Welt erzählen oder auch aus dem Prozess, wie sie entstanden ist. Ich glaube, irgendwann wird es nie langweilig, zumindest für uns nicht. Ich könnte sehr, sehr viel darüber erzählen. Es hat mir einfach wahnsinnig viel Spaß gemacht, diese Welt. Und ich würde es jederzeit wieder tun.
Ich glaube, so ein Ding ist halt auch, dass es sehr, sehr vielen Leuten auch deswegen Spaß gemacht hat, weil sie halt so eine Aufgabe hatten zwischen den Tagen. Ganz viele wären, glaube ich, sonst in so ein Loch gefallen und hätten überhaupt nichts zu tun gehabt. Und wenn ich dann so überlege, wie viele Stunden einige Assemblies irgendwie auf ihre Projekte geworfen haben, also wenn ich alleine überlege, dass es Zert, was normalerweise dafür zuständig ist, Notfälle zu behandeln auf dem realen Kongress, dass die dann irgendwie 170 Stunden darauf werfen, irgendwelche Maps zu erstellen, ist einfach unfassbar.
Also die Zert-Map hat uns vor ein paar Rätsel gestellt, das kann ich schon sagen. Wenn dann immer wieder die Karte abgeschmiert ist, bis wir dann wieder draufgekommen sind, was sie für neue Rätsel, sonst irgendwas eingebaut haben, die uns komplett vor Ressourcenproblemen bei ihren Servern gestellt haben, das war sehr interessant.
Na schön, dann würde ich an dieser Stelle trotzdem, ich glaube, es gibt wahrscheinlich noch Hunderte Stoff von Anekdoten, aber an dieser Stelle erstmal losmachen und bedanke mich bei euch für diesen Einblick hinter die Kulissen der RC3 World. Also zweifach einerseits, dass ihr das überhaupt möglich gemacht habt, also an euch vier und natürlich auch an alle anderen, die da mitgemacht haben, weil das war echt schon ein sehr cooles Event, wie ich fand und dann an euch vier ganz konkret, dass ihr heute hier im Chaosradio wart und mal ein bisschen darüber erzählt habt, wie das geht. Und vielleicht auch bei den Leuten, die sich danach gedacht haben, so was wäre ganz geil, vielleicht will ich das doch mal selber machen, diesen kleinen Funken noch ein Fach hat, das jetzt vielleicht auszuprobieren. Also Hackhörnchen, Katti, Roang und Psy, vielen Dank, dass ihr hier wart. Das freut mich sehr. Und euch, liebe HörerInnen, vielen Dank, dass ihr dabei wart. Der Podcast zu der Sendung erscheint bestimmt bald. Und dann gibt es nächsten Monat bestimmt wieder auch eine Sendung. Man weiß es nicht genau, aber bleibt uns bis dahin gewogen. Und eine wichtige Nachricht habe ich noch für euch. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.